estas condiciones son las que pusieron
los ecologistas para apoyar a la france
e insumisa del reloj pero no son de cara
a las legislativas de junio próximo y
conseguir que melanson sea el próximo
primer ministro francés la primera tiene
que ver con esta idea de desobediencia
de las normas europeas que propone menos
son en parte para poder cumplir con las
promesas de su campaña los ecologistas
han pedido que esa medida se utilice
sólo en casos extremos y concretamente
en temas económicos y de presupuesto ya
han pedido además que en el texto del
acuerdo se incluya que no habrá éxito o
salida de francia de la unión europea la
otra condición de los ecologistas es el
número de circunscripciones han pedido
ciento pero en realidad tienen
posibilidades reales en 30 de ellas y la
tercera de las condiciones tiene que ver
con el nombre del movimiento reunión
popular de melón pase a llamarse nueva
unión popular ecológica y social hoy
también tienen lugar las negociaciones
con los comunistas y los socialistas se
ve muy difícil en este partido pues si
bien el secretario general o limitó ayer
daba la mano yo lo que no son en el acto
del primero de mayo dentro del partido y
voces en contra de esta unión
concretamente el ex presidente françois
hollande o quien fuera
de agricultura stéphane le foll que de
hecho dijo que no se podía sacrificar la
historia del partido por 20
circunscripciones y también se opone el
ex secretario general de los socialistas
ya christophe cambadélis que dice que no
se puede aceptar esta idea de europa que
tienen la razón ellos son europeístas
convencidos además tampoco está baja de
la edad a 60 años de jubilación dice que
es impracticable que va a endeudar el
país y también hay diferencias en temas
como la otan y también como la guerra en
ucrania y si no los comunistas parecen
más dispuestos a llegar a un acuerdo
pero aún hay diferencias que limar